Yeah,
so a big question,
uh,
if,
if anybody's seen the movie minority
report where people are arrested for
crimes before they actually commit them,
just because the data suggests they're
going to commit a crime.
Uh,
are we entering this world with so much
data available?
Uh,
and are definitely our clues on the
Internet that people are considering
committing a crime.
I mean,
people really do tie how to kill your
girlfriend on Google or a how to commit
a murder.
Uh,
and uh,
so what should we do with this
information as a society?
I think we have to be really,
really careful.
Uh,
there's uh,
an ethical and privacy reasons to be
careful as a society.
It's not supposed to be illegal to have
bad thoughts,
uh,
but I think there's also a data science
reason for this.
One of the things that you do see in
this data is that a lot of people have
horrific thoughts or make horrific
searches without ever going through with
a horrific action.
Uh,
so it may be that when we have all this
data,
we think we're going to be able to
figure out like exactly who's at risk of
committing a crime or doing something
bad,
but it may be that it's just really,
really hard because a huge percentage of
people look really,
really bad on paper,
uh,
but never go through with the action.
There's a study of prosper,
a peer to peer lending,
uh,
from,
so people can apply for loans and
scholars analyzed the loan application,
what people wrote in their loan
application and whether they paid back
their loan and they found that you could
predict whether someone will pay back
the loan based on the words that person
used in their loan application.
So if a person uses the phrase,
I promise they're are much less likely
to pay back a loan because I guess
everybody lies.
So I promise is a,
is a clue that you're not going to pay
back the loan.
And one of them,
one of the more striking indicators,
one of the single highest indicators
you're not going to pay back a loan is
if you use the word God in your loan
application,
uh,
and this is kind of a little bit eerie
and suggest a potentially dark future.
It means that someone,
a lender would be wise to not give a
loan to anybody who mentions God.
If someone says,
God bless you,
uh,
in a loan application,
they are put together in a large group
of other people who tend on average not
to pay back their loans.
So there's real danger to some of this
big data where a lot of the correlation,
everything kind of correlates with
everything else.
And sometimes for reasons that we have,
don't understand some words people use
or likes they have on facebook,
predict that they're going to do bad
things even if they're not really going
to do bad things.
And they may be punished without even
realizing why.
Uh,
one thing you see in the Google search
data related to religion is the
questions people have and they're
usually concentrated in the Bible belt.
Uh,
but people have kind of loaded about
God.
So why does God allow bad things to
happen to good people are,
why does God allow suffering?
Or why does God needs so much praise?
Uh,
these are questions that people might
not raise a loud because,
uh,
you know,
they don't want to share their doubts
with others,
but they turn to Google and ask them
really,
really loaded questions about the
stories that they hear a related to
religion.